- Oh my God, you're so lucky.
The trans lifestyle is so in right now.
So in right now!
- The (beep)?
- What's your real name?
(beeps)
- Hey Jimmy, so this is Rocco.
She's been with us for about a year now.
(glass breaking)
(horn blaring)
- Do you think I could take some of your
testosterone, it would
like get rid of my period?
(ringing)
(meowing)
- So what do you think of Caitlyn Jenner?
(ringing)
- Trans guys are so hot.
It's like the best of both worlds.
(squawking)
- So, um, do you do drag?
(ringing)
(horn blaring)
- You're pretty for a trans woman.
- Aw, (squeeking) you.
- You really look like a real man.
- (glass breaking) you.
- Do you still have a penis?
- Oh my (beep).
- Wait, you got the surgery?
Dude, can I see your dick?
- (Beeps) no.
- Oh my God, you're trans?
I love gay people.
(horn blaring)
- I'm not gay, I'm trans.
They're two different things.
Gender and sexuality.
You can have gender without a sexuality
but you can't have
sexuality without gender.
So I'm trans and I'm
straight because I date women
and I'm a man.